schluss mit der romantik hier geht es um
die wahren ursachen der liebe und die
haben mit romantik so viel zu tun wie
eine sommerwiese mit einer dampfmaschine
thema heute chemie der liebe im valentin
swat special von krieg zum science
fiction heute auf den was geht ab
studios in berlin und das ist dominik
und das ist christoph
sorry wissenschaftlich betrachtet gibt
es gar keine liebe der natur geht es
nämlich nur darum ob wir gesunde
kräftige kinder zeugen und nicht mehr
und auch nicht weniger
schuld daran ob wir uns in jemanden
verliebt sind die humanen leukozyten
antigene kurz hla der evolutionsbiologe
klaus wenig hin konnte das für 1995
nachweisen
er ließ frauen an t shirts riechen die
männer drei tage lang getragen haben
je unterschiedlicher die dort gewonnenen
hla gene waren umso angenehmer wurde der
geruch empfunden das heißt dass die
natur und steuert und zwar dahin wo die
wahrscheinlichkeit am größten ist das
der beste nachwuchs gezeugt wird und das
passiert wenn möglichst viele
unterschiedliche halogene zusammenkommen
zudem verlieren wir uns leichter wenn
frauen ihren eisprung haben
dann findet männer sie besonders sexy
und fliegt auch wieder am geruch sind
frauen fruchtbar sondern sie vermehrt
pheromone ab und locken damit männer
dazu gibt es sogar eine etwas skurrile
studie job will miller berichtete 2007
in der fachzeitschrift evolution and
human behavior über die untersuchung des
trinkgeld das stripperin bekommen bei
seiner testgruppe von 18 stripperin
bekam die tänzerin die einen eisprung
hatten während dieser zeit doppelt so
viel trinkgeld stripperin die die pille
nahm und dementsprechend keinen
einspruch hatten bekamen immer dasselbe
trinkgeld strittig ist jetzt nur noch ob
es an den phänomenen lag oder ob die
stripperin mit eisprung erotischer
getanzt haben
natürlich kommt es beim verlieben aber
auch aufs aussehen an das hat aber auch
wieder mit chemie zu tun
frauen stehen auf markante gesichtszüge
und männliches aussehen merkmale die
einen starken beschützer für ihre
zukünftigen kinder erwarten lässt mit
verursachen für dieses aussehen ist das
männliche sexualhormon testosteron
ähnlich ist es bei frauen bei ihm
verursacht östrogen wie weibliche
körperform und ebenmäßige gesichtszüge
alles in allem kann man sagen stimmt die
chemie zwischen zwei menschen verlieben
sie sich und was passiert dann
dann kommt die chemie
so richtig in gang und zwar im kopf das
gehirn ist nämlich unser größtes liebes
und sexualleben
hier zählt nämlich jetzt vor allem eins
es muss ausreichend oxytocin
ausgeschüttet werden
das gehirn hat nämlich den bereich im
belohnungssystem aktiviert indem die
meisten rezeptoren für dieses hormon
existieren wenn es also so richtig funkt
dann wird viel oxytocin ausgeschüttet
und die wahrscheinlichkeit der
dauerhaften paarbindung steigt deutlich
an
jetzt noch ein wenig war so pretzien das
ist ein hormon das diese bindung noch
unterstützt und damit eben für eine
treue bindung für vielleicht alle
ewigkeit na ja schon einmal
gewährleistet damit wäre dann auch
übrigens alles da was für die erste
heiße liebesnacht nötig ist oxytocin
sorgt für die muskelkontraktion die
nötige während des orgasmus und war so
presse sichert die optimale
blutversorgung der geschlechtsorgane
dann kann also nichts mehr schiefgehen
aber damit man so richtig liebeskranke
mit gehören noch die aufputschmittel
dopamin und adrenalin dazu und der
serotoninspiegel sinkt das ist jetzt
allerdings paradox denn serotonin gilt
eigentlich als glückshormon und genau
das soll jetzt deutlich weniger
ausgeschüttet werden
die ursachen des akuten mangels bei
verliebten tatsächlich noch nicht
geklärt dass man kann einfach nicht
sagen wieso die serotonin spiegel sinken
aber der zustand von sehr niedrigen
termin spiegel ist will kann zum
beispiel auch bei psychisch kranken oder
bei psychisch kranken ist sind die
serotoninspiegel noch deutlich geringer
als beispielsweise bei verliefen aber im
prinzip wieder in die gleiche richtung
diese psychisch kranken zum beispiel
leute mit zwangsstörungen die von etwas
manisches besessen sind und ja da ist
dann eben noch weniger serotonin
vorhanden als bei den verliebten und bei
verliebten ist es ja quasi auch so die
sind ja quasi auch von jemandem besessen
sozusagen also es geht tatsächlich in
die gleiche richtung und so hat die
liebe und das verliebtsein eben auch
etwas manisches liebeskranke ist damit
wohl die absolut passende bezeichnung
und es ist so auch verständlich warum
verliebtsein auch immer ein bisschen wie
eine
kyte ist bei aller liebeskranken also
gute besserung
was meint ihr ist liebe wirklich nur
eine sache der chemie also reine
naturwissenschaft und hat es mit
romantik gefühlen und einer höheren
macht zu tun
eure meinung in die kommentare wenn ihr
mehr sehen wollt zur valentin sword
aktion dann klickt in das video von
chrissi und hier und da geht es in die
playlist zum valentinstag mit allen
videos zu diesem großen ereignissen
ansonsten würde ich mal sagen bis dann
bleibt dran